if she slept with more people she's not
she's more likely to cheat and if a guy
has slept with more people it's not the
same okay
um if uh because it's the thing is a
dude can be broke short and ran through
as well men and women aren't the same
either way
but this is the thing guys if you look
at the other side of it yeah
a man is a woman when they have sex
right A man is coming inside of you yeah
like you end up holding on to that like
sperm doesn't just leave your body so I
get there's a certain level in terms of
like how many partners you should be
with and how accessible you are to a man
and just anyone and everyone but
I get the sense of like I wouldn't if I
was a man I wouldn't want a woman that's
just been with everyone I wouldn't want
as a woman I don't want a man that's
been with exactly and and I so why do
you say that a hoe deserves to be
courted like why should another dude put
up with that because if even if she she
may have had sex with other people one
to be honest let's be very very honest a
hoe is probably gonna make you come
faster than a virgin so she probably
will what what you want from her she can
probably give it to you better than a
virgin can a home will probably still be
able to cook still be able to clean
still be able to educate your kids if
you're broke and you're short you won't
be able to provide it
short your size but the one the one
thing that you're missing is that men
value loyalty and the point that Paul's
trying to make is that she might be able
to clean like you said she might be able
to cook she might she might exhibit all
of these traits right however and she
might she might give you good sex but
men value loyalty I've given her sexual
status she's far less money need to be
loyal that's what men are aiming for
it's the thing is right like that is
still uh
that's still like a a maybe she might be
less loyal it's also equally happy
okay you said you said you saw my Tick
Tock right oh yeah I said like you said
you were you were before the show you
said you were triggered by my Tick Tock
sure not triggered you were upset you
were you felt sometimes
I felt
I feltful and you sometimes you're
irresponsible with the things that you
say do you know which thing upset me the
the five body count one no not that okay
when you when a girl said that she spent
her twenties finding yours herself and
you said what does that mean you don't
spend but so many women have to take
time finding themselves you were raised
in a really beautiful home with a
beautiful family with five older
brothers that looked after you not
everybody
there's a girl on your own but you had
siblings that helped you build character
and helped you feel comfortable with who
you are not everybody has that same
footage I understand that but the point
is the world doesn't owe you
understanding so yeah no but you are
when you're saying that like you deserve
to be courted by someone like the key
word is deserved nobody deserves
anything no can I ask a question can I
ask a question sorry go ahead
um so imagine you've got two guys right
you've got one guy average height
average looks average income right
they've got the second guy right two
good looking confident intelligent
clearly there's one guy you would you
want more and there's one guy who's seen
as more valuable to you because of what
you look for than the other right so
would you be expected right because it's
going to be harder to get him yeah right
would you be expected to the same degree
the same level of effort that you put in
to get his attention to connect with him
right would you expect to have the same
level of effort for the guy that you
find less valuable you're gonna have to
redirect the question because I don't
chase
so basically if I just put in a mutual
amount of effort so if that's that
intelligent whatever guy that's there he
can be there and they can be the average
guy if the average guy is building more
of a relationship with me or making more
effort with me that's who so you don't
you don't reciprocate in dating no I
only reciprocate I don't I'm not going
to it I'm supposed to let him know
you're interested basically yeah exactly
because that's what he's saying if you
had two men in front of you how would
you like how are you going to choose
you're automatically going to change I'm
not gonna want a guy that wants me to
chase him okay it's not about chasing
that's my point if you have two
opportunities like both of them don't
know about each other and you're
speaking to them both you're
automatically going to choose the one
that is more suited to you like you're
not going to choose the one just because
of or unless you care more about
personality depending on what your
values are I do care more about
personality so how do you choose and
he's saying like how would you do that
so if you're the last woman on Earth you
decide you have to decipher the value
but let me quickly ask you a question so
just just a little look into a man's
brain right regardless what anyone wants
to say men off the bat we want to have
sex right so you said previously that
every single woman should be caught with
this thing okay everyone should be
caught with the same so if a man was to
court a woman say over three months
hypothetically right the mouse caught a
woman over three months he spent his
time money resources all of his energy
on you do you believe once he's done
that you owe him sex no I don't believe
I owe him anything but if I want to have
sex with him I'll have sex with him
but he has to do all this stuff for you
that's the biggest thing you're not
doing anything other hand I didn't say
I'm not going to do anything for him I
said I said that women deserve to be
courted so I think that all women
deserve especially and I think as well
it's the intention that you have for the
woman so if you're dating women to find
your like life partner
then yeah then definitely you should
take time to court them properly if
you're dating women to [ __ ] then call
date woman to [ __ ] well even so even the
women that say oh men are trash men are
XYZ men don't deserve this from me men
don't need this from me I'm a like uh
Kevin Samuel says I'm a independent
woman I can do things on my own like
why why do they need to be courted if
they can do it on their own they can
take themselves out to them they can
take their self they can Court
themselves essentially why do they why
do they deserve to be courted if they're
not essentially going to give
reciprocate the reciprocated for the man
so the thing is for me right I feel that
relationships and you're probably all
gonna attack me for this but it's what I
feel and what I believe I feel
relationships marriage is more
advantageous for men than it is for
women I feel that men need women more
than women need men and because of that
men should make more efforts and like
yeah even if those women that feel that
men are trash men are this or all of
those types of women they can either
choose to be single and they'll be happy
or if a man wants them that man should
work to prove them wrong and work to
have them on their side
how do women how do met you said women
or men need women more than women need
men yeah how is that true when they want
everything that in society what do you
mean everything the power supply the
entire infrastructure of society oh it's
it's very simple it's because that
construction needs sex more than women
need sex but can I just quickly say
that's all you offer
that's not all you offer generally
speaking the things that you believe you
offer a man we point blank don't give a
[ __ ] about yeah you can offer
personality you can offer the ability to
clean the house unless you're loyal and
the pussy's good we genuinely don't give
a [ __ ] more than any so basically I know
all men really care about is sex
basically as well in the beginning yeah
all men care about is sex and every
woman has the ability to give a man sex
basically and so what do women need from
Men
sustainability suitability wait wait
pause protection from what if someone
breaks into your house who who protects
you the people
[Music]
do men not run the police department the
fire department no no those are those
are men in society I'm talking about men
in your relationships
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible